the Little Stranger is a British horror
that due to studio neglect may have
flown under the radar for many however
the film is fantastic and possesses an
ending that leaves a lot to unpack
throughout this video I will be
discussing several plot details from The
Little Stranger so there will be heavy
spoilers with that out the way I'm
definition and I ruin the movie so you
don't have to the film follows dr.
Farraday as he makes a visit to a
dilapidated mansion named hundred's Hall
Farraday frequented the mansion as a
child and became fascinated with it as
the movie goes on the circumstances that
surround the occupants of the mansion
become more and more tragic and we learn
that Farraday himself is hiding a lot of
aspects about his true nature in the
final shot of the film we see the
spectral image of a child Farraday
hovering above his fatally wounded
fiancee committed suicide during the
movie many are unsure whether this was a
real ghost or not and whilst the
Internet is awash with interpretations
on what the final shot means director
lenny abrahamson cleared up his vision
in a recent interview with Thrillist
Abrahamson stated that the film is a
ghost story but it's a ghost story in an
older tradition if you look at Dickens
as ghost stories there's an attempt to
use the form to tell you something about
people or the culture where it's from
what I'd found so compelling about what
Sara the author did with the novel is
that she'd used this ghost story idea to
talk about the sorts of things that are
in people that they desperately tried to
suppress and the effect that has on
one's life if there are destructive
things or longings or regrets or needs
and fulfill that you suppress then they
will come out somehow to spite you they
will wreck the rest of your life
this definitely backs up Faraday's
character or throughout the film and
during the movie we watch him change
from a mild-mannered man into a vengeful
and hateful misogynist when asked if
there's a ghost in the house Faraday
said
there is a ghost or there is a thing in
the house as will poulter says in the
character of rowdy there's a thing in
the house that hates us Abrahamson
stated that I think whether it hates
them as a question you could ask but I
think there is a thing in the house now
I don't believe in any such things in
reality but in the story world of this
film I think it's really important there
is some truth to it but quite a long
part of the film you can go well I don't
know maybe Faraday is right maybe it's
all in people's heads and it's an
overactive imagination and stuff but
actually I think as a part of the film
where you just go okay there's no other
explanation
but it's what that thing is where it
comes from and what it means that's
ambiguous in the film this is obviously
a bit confusing and when describing what
he meant Abrahamson stated that you go
back to the tradition of the jekyll and
hyde story mr. Hyde the monster is all
the bad bits of the person of dr. Jekyll
Faraday is someone who was so
desperately longing for love and
acceptance but who doesn't know how to
get it he is unaware of the mr. Hyde
it's some kind of version of his
childish rage and longing to me this
clears up a lot of ambiguity and leaves
the final shot with a more concrete
conclusion in my opinion the film's end
signifies that we should be careful what
we wish for as it may come true
Faraday in the end gets what the child
always wanted which was the expansive
house however he doesn't get the things
that make a house a home instead he's
left with the bricks and mortar but he
is still completely alone to inhabit it
after pushing everyone else away the
piece leaves me to believe that we
shouldn't act upon impulses I say can
lead us down a dark path like the one
that Faraday finds himself on so what
did you take from the little stranger
comment below and let me know and make
sure you check out the full interview
with through a list linked in the
description if you enjoyed this video
then please like it and subscribe to my
channel as I create content like this
weekly and they'll definitely be
something on here that you love if
you're a fan of
make sure you check out my breakdown of
the new Netflix film hold the dock which
will be linked at the end of this one
and thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]